strap on in it's everyone's favorite
buzz
buzz buzz
buzz
no none of those to infinity
and beyond not even that one because we
have a new buzz lightyear voiced by none
other than captain america himself i
could do this all day disney pixar's
latest space adventure is a wild time
traveling ride that gives us the origin
of one of andy's favorite toys so join
me as we break down the entire movie and
some of the details you may have missed
along the way lightyear is the movie
that andy from toy story 1 loves so much
he got buzz as a toy for him during his
sixth birthday any dinosaur-shaped ones
oh
in boxes you idiot i guess you could say
this is kind of like a movie within a
movie but before all the events of toy
story buzz was on an intergalactic
mission to find a new home for humanity
and while 4.2 million miles away from
earth on a star command exploration
vessel affectionately called the turnip
he is unexpectedly awoken from cryosleep
to investigate a new planet while the
scientists and workers remain in their
slumber he must determine whether this
new planet is good enough for them to
settle or if they should pack up and
continue back to their original
destination one of the first things he
says when he gets onto this new planet
happens to be the same exact thing he
says when he arrives in andy's room
there seems to be no sign of an
intelligent life you'll notice him
wearing his iconic star ranger spacesuit
which is one of many different suits
he'll wear over the course of the movie
a new addition to the suit which we get
to see in action is the laser blade
which mattel toys has started releasing
with their buzz lightyear action figures
awaking with him is commander alicia
hawthorne voiced by uzu adubat and a
rookie named feathering stenham try
saying that five times fast have you
ever wondered how pixar is so good at
making us care about their characters
and how their movies have so much
emotion it starts right at the beginning
with a character who is deeply flawed
who then goes on a journey and comes out
a better person and at the beginning of
light year we see a couple of buzz's
flaws he's arrogant thinks he can do
everything by himself and always puts
the mission before his friends but if
buzz is going to grow as a person he'll
need to learn how to work with others
and ultimately put friends and family
before anything else buzz and the team
try to escape the planet but he ends up
crashing the turnip breaking the
hyper-speed crystal necessary for space
travel and stranding everyone there and
they're there for an entire year before
the colony can even attempt stabilizing
a new fuel source buzz plans on testing
out this new fuel stability by lassoing
around the sun and hitting hyperspeed a
trip that should only take about four
minutes however the mission goes
terribly wrong and fails but when he
arrives back to the planet he finds out
four years two months and three days
have passed what was only four minutes
for him was four years for them this was
the result of something albert einstein
called time dilation you might have seen
this in the movie interstellar or even
here in real life in 2015 astronaut
scott kelly went into space for an
entire year and when he came back his
twin brother who was on earth the whole
time was five milliseconds older than
him so you can imagine how much faster
buzz had to have been going for four
years to pass to cheer buzz up from his
failed mission alicia gives him an
adorable robot cat named socks i am sox
your personal companion robot my what
he's honestly one of the best parts of
the movie buzz feels responsible for
getting everyone stuck here and it
becomes his mission to right this wrong
and get everyone back on course but each
time he keeps going into space and
trying that hyper speed more time passes
and alicia having been on the planet
this whole time becomes an old lady buzz
has missed all those important times in
her life her getting married having kids
and even a granddaughter buzz has spent
so much time fighting for a life he
himself has forgotten how to live one
and on his last failed mission he
returns home to find that alicia has
passed away for me it was one of the
most emotional scenes in the entire
movie the new commander burnside decides
to axe buzz's mission and instead have
humanity live under a giant laser shield
this also means socks will be
decommissioned but there's just one
problem over these past 60 years that
buzz has been flying into space sox has
finally come up with the perfect
calculation to make the fuel stable
enough to reach hyperspeed so buzz has
to run from the authorities and escape
the planet even though he's been told
his mission's been terminated but we
know buzz does what he wants and he
successfully evades capture and ventures
into space to prove once and for all he
can complete the mission and complete it
he does returning back to earth 22 years
later but something very bad has
happened since he was gone a week before
his arrival an alien spaceship has
surrounded the colony and only a few
remain to fight back it's here buzz
teams up with alicia's granddaughter
izzy who is now all grown up the alien
spaceship is controlled by zerg who you
may remember first seeing in toy story 2
and played a much larger role in the
buzz lightyear of star command
television show he is the sworn enemy of
the galactic alliance and arch enemy of
buzz and there's a big twist surrounding
him in this movie but we'll get into
that in a bit so buzz makes it to
outpost 3 where we meet the rest of
izzy's ragtag crew there's mo voiced by
taiko ati and our favorite elderly
convict darby a real no-nonsense gruff
type who can take any three objects and
make them explode there they go over the
plan for operation surprise party which
entails blowing up the alien ship so the
robots below break down it could be a
coincidence but the buzz lightyear
action figure andy got for his birthday
was a surprise and not in his original
pile of presents but this plan has one
major problem they need a ship but
luckily there's one in the abandoned
bug-infested space dock what could go
wrong it's in this scene we really see
how buzz still has a long way to go to
overcome his flaw of accepting help he
still wants to do everything on his own
and it actually gets them all into a
heap ton of trouble with the entire crew
narrowly making out of the depot with
the ship after evading a giant bug
attack but just when it looks like
they've made an escape zerg attacks the
ship crash landing it on the dark side
of the planet luckily the nearby
terrillium mine just might have the part
needed to fix their ship so they make
their way over it's here we get a
heartfelt story from buzz who tells a
story about how he almost quit star
academy in the first week he kept making
mistakes but it was his grandma who told
him to keep going only by making
mistakes can we get better and that's a
lesson buzz seems to have forgotten has
he made mistakes sure but he has to get
up and keep trying this will be tested
even further when they're attacked by
zerg and his gang of robots the weird
thing here is that zerg only seems to be
after buzz but why in a spectacular
space chase across the planet's lava
fields zerg's robots gain control of the
hyper-speed fuel and teleport back to
the ship everything buzz has worked for
for more than 80 years is gone in an
instant he finally concedes that his
mission is over but if things couldn't
get any worse buzz is attacked by zerg
and teleported to the alien ship but
zerg doesn't want to kill him in fact
the big reveal is that zerg is buzzed
well a much much older version than
himself so how on earth is this possible
this buzz comes from an alternate
timeline one in which the hyper speed
fuel actually worked but he had to
escape burnside who expressly told him
that the mission was over and that he's
now to be arrested so this buzz escapes
takes the hyper-speed fuel with him and
travels so far into the future that he
uncovered an alien ship with futuristic
tech it was here he discovered that if
you could use this fuel to go into the
future why not the past so he ends up
using the rest of the fuel to travel
back in time exactly one week before our
buzz lands on the planet now that he has
young buzz's fuel the two of them can go
back in time together and reset
everything so the colony can venture off
to its original destination as planned
but young buzz is met with a dilemma
does he follow old buzz's plan to
complete the mission or does he refuse
and go with his friends if he goes with
old buzz it means izzy will no longer
exist alicia will never have lived the
full life she had and not to mention
countless others it's buzz's decision
not to help old buzz that proves he
truly puts others before himself and the
mission of course old buzz or zerg as
i'll call him is not happy about this
and the two battle it out luckily buzz
has his friends there to help him
something he said he never needed at the
beginning of the movie izzy also has to
overcome her fear of space to save him
and even darby and mo hold back a horde
of robots buzz sets a self-destruct on
the big alien ship and is able to
teleport to his smaller ship using the
same alien teleportation device the
robots used but there's one final battle
as buzz's ship crash lands to earth zerg
appears out of nowhere and rips the
hyper-speed fuel out of the ship and in
a heroic scene where we get to see buzz
use his space wings for the first time
he blasts zerg into space but at the
same time loses the fuel that could save
him with the entire crew safely back on
the planet and the colony saved izzy
asks if buzz will miss home now that he
has no way of getting back but he tells
her this now feels like home and
although he's chewed out by burnside for
his actions buzz is ultimately given
full command of the space rangers with
the ability to choose the best of the
best to join his ranks but he tells
burnside he already has the best crew
izzy moe and darby well let's not forget
socks and the last line of the movie is
the iconic to infinity and beyond the
stubborn-headed buzz at the beginning of
the film who only did things on his own
and cared only about the mission has
completely turned into the opposite one
who supports his friends and puts them
before anything else now six-year-old
andy would have come out of the theater
loving this movie and telling his mom
just how much he wants a buzz lightyear
action figure now there are three extra
scenes after the movie finishes two of
them don't really add anything to the
story but one leaves room open for a
potential sequel now these are really
short so i won't spend a lot of time
talking about them but the first is a
burnside watching a bug zap on the laser
shield the second is a robot explaining
the directions on how to get to the
space depot and the third is the big one
we see zerg floating through space and
his eyes turn back on
will zerg return in one form or another
and how does he escape the depths of
space but what did you think of
lightyear was this a step into the
future or should disney have left this
toy behind i want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at think story yt until
next time remember that was utterly
terrifying and i regret having joined
you
you